[Music]
well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages time to see then what is
making the headlines with the political
editor of the daily mirror pippa clara
and the editor of the jewish chronicle
jake wallace simons lovely to see you
both and i know you're both with us
until just before midnight so let's
crack on with the front pages then
the guardian leads with the resumption
of peace talks over ukraine and those
claims that roman abramovich was
poisoned along with other talks
delegates at a previous session earlier
this month
the daily mail also focusing on the
suspected poisoning of mr abramovic
adding that the russian billionaire was
blinded and lost his site for several
hours after the incident
dft carries a warning from the governor
of the bank of england that rising
prices will cause britain's what he
calls a historic shock to their incomes
meanwhile the daily telegraph reports
that scotland yard is expected to issue
the first fines over partygate
imminently
after concluding that covert laws were
broken at the heart of government
duke back on parade the metro says
prince andrew will attend his late
father's memorial service his first
public appearance since settling his sex
abuse allegations case in the united
states
the eye reports that the uk's new energy
strategy is being delayed because of a
row between the prime minister and the
chancellor over the cost of building new
nuclear power stations
hollywood pawn shop is the headline for
the sun referring to that moment where
will smith slapped chris rock during the
oscar ceremony the paper says the
academy has now launched a formal review
into the incident
well a reminder by scanning the qr code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
so let's bring in then uh pippa clearer
and jake wallace simons hello to both of
you
and straight to the guardian jake and
this intriguing story about what
happened to the uh the chelsea owner
this is a very very strange story indeed
so apparently um roman abramovich has
been engaging in some intermediary work
trying to mediate between the russians
and ukrainians to try to find some
resolution to this war
and in early march he was engaging in a
visit on the border of belarus for this
purpose and
ended up having eaten nothing but
chocolate and drunk nothing but water
that evening
ended up becoming blinded for a number
of hours having peeling skin and
stabbing pains in his eyes and also
peeling skin on his hands as well but
not only he suffered those symptoms but
also members of the ukrainian delegation
were with him
suffered it as well so it seems like
this attack was in some strange way
either indiscriminate or botched or
wasn't an attack it was something else
um and nobody really knows what happened
whether it was an intentional poisoning
some sort of chemical weapons attack or
some sort of environmental
issue which the american sources have
been suggesting
um but either way um you know it is a
very very troubling affair and it shows
how much cloak and dagger stuff really
does go on in these sort of situations i
should add that the mail was reporting
today
um that the attack was perpetrated by
moscow hardliners who are trying to
derail the talks so who knows what's
really going on but the males seem to
take that line absolutely and the the
claims first reported by the wall street
journal and the investigative journalism
outlet bellingcat um bellingham
suggesting the symptoms included eye and
skin inflammation piercing pain in the
eyes added that the three men recovered
quickly and the us
suggesting that the evidence did not
point to poisoning um but it all leads
into the talks which are expected to
take place uh tomorrow in istanbul and
presumably security and everybody
watching carefully what they eat and
drink their pepper
well you'd have thought so and i mean
the role of abramovich and all of this
is really as jake rightly says
fascinating not least because he was one
of the
most high profile oligarchs to be
sanctioned by the uk and it was some
suggestion that the u.s treasury
initially held off on sanctioning him
because he had suggested that he might
be able to be to step in to try and help
de-escalate um the crisis in ukraine and
help even rebuild ukraine afterwards he
of course is incredibly close to
vladimir putin um
but then of course we now see a
situation where he's been sanctioned and
all of this sort of overshadows really
the first face-to-face talks between the
two countries between the ukraine and
russia which being held in istanbul uh
tomorrow the first face-to-face talks
for two weeks i should say
they have met before
and i think there's very little hope in
all of the papers that are reporting on
this there seems to be very little hope
that there's going to be any imminent
breakthrough or even any breakthrough at
all but um the very fact that um the
meeting at all does sort of suggest that
the dynamic has shifted a little bit in
the last couple of weeks when you also
take into account the military situation
on the ground the fact that russia's
approach approaches and attempts to
encircle heave look like they are so far
unsuccessful and that they've they've
obviously had such sort of a blow to the
logistics and support um
system on the ground which has which has
resulted in in this conflict going on
for much longer than they'd initially
anticipated so you know there are
various factors on the table uh
different papers mentioned different
ones neutrality is a is a key one
because obviously spoken about that in
the last 24 hours whether it could be
enforced by some sort of international
um
security guarantees
uh whether the the contested bits of
ukraine both the crimea and the east and
donbass could effectively have some sort
of uh you know slightly autonomous role
um that's something that that silence
has resisted so far but it could yet
happen
um and of course the you know the key
and most immediate one is the is the
withdrawal of russian troops from the
rest of ukraine so
no major no suggestion that there's
gonna be an imminent breakthrough in any
of those but you've got to take some
hope for the fact that the meeting at
all yes and the ft uh talking about
ukrainian forces regaining ground
specifically in this uh northwesterly
area
of kiev the urpin which we all remember
because that's the bridge that was
destroyed and everyone all refugees were
fleeing there you know under bombardment
including people you know the infirm
being carried in shopping trolleys so
that really sticks in the mind and all
of this jake coming as joe biden spoke
again tonight saying um about this idea
of whether he was calling for regime
change at the back end of last week i
was expressing he said the moral outrage
that i felt towards this man i wasn't
articulating a policy change so will
will that put this all to bed do you
think
i think that um the russians might not
see it uh in quite such a generous way
as mr biden is hoping
um it's all very well finn to try to
roll back after the event but these
comments matter you know our own prime
minister has made a few foreign policy
gaffes in the past not least with
regards and doesn't need to go i
ratcliff if you remember that and these
things do matter because our enemies
take them very seriously and then the
idea that they would say that was just a
sip of the time and let's overlook it
and perhaps is fanciful um but it is
interesting nonetheless that the ukraine
uh is making these big gains uh in the
war and very encouraging as well in fact
from that uh that small ft story that
you just splashed up on the screen a
couple of minutes ago i was interested
to see that according to u.s defense
sources ukrainians are still in control
of maria
and i had thought frankly that mario
paul had been all but obliterated and
that ukrainians had been routed by the
russians and it was a humanitarian
castro and of course it is a
humanitarian catastrophe but the fact
that ukrainian forces still in control
of that city is a mark of how well
they're doing relatively in this war and
how much cause to hope there is at the
moment tentative hope but hope
nonetheless
right so we move on to partygate pippa
uh you can obviously take this one away
um right what are we expecting uh will
this be the first tranche of fines and
will the prime minister be included
so there's been a bit of a hiatus in the
whole partygate affair as the police
have investigated and quite
understandably a lot of the tensions
focused away from domestic issues
to what's been going on in ukraine
but we've had suggestions tonight from
sources
that the police are
on the verge on the cost provisioning
their first round of
we're expecting maybe 15 or 20 people to
be issued to fix penalty notices
tomorrow confirming that there was law
breaking at the heart of downing street
in government um during lockdown with
those social gatherings
um it is as you rightly say just the
first tranche the expectation is that
there will be more to follow not least
because um
really quite
substantial number of people received uh
questionnaires from the police some of
them only really in the last couple of
weeks so
um the police will only really just got
that information back so this is the
first wave we're not expecting the prime
minister to be amongst those tomorrow uh
the sources are suggesting that it's
sort of the uncontested
non-controversial
um individuals the breaches that will be
they'll be focused on with this first
wave of course the prime minister is
anything but um unconscious um
controversial or um uncontested and his
involvement in it so expect to see that
further down the line and there's also
some suggestion that krista dick who's
the outgoing commissioner due to step
down to leave the met
in the middle of next month middle of
april is keen to have this inquiry done
and dusted by the time she leaves so she
doesn't need to hand it along to her
successor whether that is in fact in her
gift um as this inquiry continues we've
had more than a hundred questionnaires
sent out as say there's 12 separate
gatherings being investigated six of
which at least six of which the prime
minister was said to have been at
himself um you know hundreds of photos
and documents for the police to to sort
of pour over
whether her hopes of it all being
resolved by the time she leaves our
deliverable um you know remains in doubt
okay fascinating well we'll certainly
watch out for that won't we on tuesday
um plenty more still to come in the next
part of our program including the
fallout after all that drama at the
oscars back
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now the political
editor of the daily mirror pipakura and
the editor of the jewish chronicle jake
wallace simons welcome back to both of
you um jake let's go to the guardian
shall we in the inside pages too of
which there's plenty of coverage uh the
slap at the oscars
this has been the biggest story of the
past 24 hours on twitter anyway
will smith uh
slapped chris rock on stage after the
comedian had insulted his girlfriend and
um sorry his wife vega pun and uh you
know for me i think this is really a
head and heart issue you know for my
head i can you know i find it difficult
to condone this kind of behavior but in
my heart i feel that if the insult was
so egregious and so public it's hard not
to feel some sympathy for will smith at
losing it so i think uh a lot of us
would have been hard-pressed to prevent
ourselves from acting the same way if a
similar insult had been leveled with our
wives or fiancees or girlfriends so
i've got a feel a lot of sympathy for
him but my head says no no this is
unacceptable well i mean this is what
what do the academy members think too uh
the metro reporting that uh smith may be
stripped of his oscar you know the
highlight of his career at that moment
pippa a slap in the face they call it
yeah well this source is quoted on the
front of the metro saying that he might
be stripped of his oscar but then whoopi
goldberg who's one of the governors of
the academy says that they're not going
to take his oscar away you know he can't
help but think that this hasn't really
worked out very well for anyone not lee
smith himself who's of course won his
first oscar and this is overshadowed
that event but also the ceremony more
generally which had i think had
numerous examples of diversity
breakthroughs um in terms of the awards
and uh you know this is overshadowed
that as well with this trial over
whether he should or shouldn't have
slapped chris rock and uh brought up all
sorts of issues about uh violence and
you know the wake of the metoo movement
the academy who drew up um a code of
conduct
which has driven these calls for him to
be stripped of the award but then of
course historically this whole loot of
little controversial figures that that
could possibly apply to that it hasn't
so
yeah i'd be surprised if they did
actually end up doing that a quick 30
seconds on the other store on the front
page of the metro jake if you don't mind
which is
prince andrew
what's the suggestion here
prince andrew is appearing in public for
the first time since the european report
since he pays a reported 12 million
pounds uh to his accuser to settle the
sex case without taking any guilt on
board um and the event he's attending is
the memorial service for his father uh
the late uh prince philip and i just
feel that yes it's you know it sticks in
the throat to see him in public in this
sort of way but at the same time it's a
memorial service for his father and it'd
be difficult to describe anybody with
that
jake wallace simons pippa career thank
you both very much indeed thank you